あああっお兄ちゃんへ日あ来てっにょちょっと話したいことは一つあるんですけどもう
見ぬファンとかって使ってますでしょうか
僕も
いつも使っているビックがあるんですよこちらです論議法廷で何かな3000円くらい
から完全くらいで買ったんですけど気づいたらもう多分23年くらい使ってって絵本と
葱の本と昨日の出来事だったんですけども
[拍手]
ん
ああああああ
ハエトリで壊れてしまったんですけど本当に43年間落ち答えたといいたい俺は素直に
このカバーを褒めたい
本当によく頑張ったと思ってますだってその次乱暴に扱っていた節もあるかもしれませ
んがそんなで超欄まで使ってなくて普通に使っててドンキで買ってよく3年間も俺に
着いてきてくれたなぁと思ってますからもう猫の背中のかけるこの
人にすごいというのはかけてるんですよ
[音楽]
ども野党誰だなんないのか背中て背中にかけているこの
右肩の部分のもう完全に
ドイツ位
ブチッちゃって look としての機能を使い終えてしまいましたドンキで買った
キュリアスのリュックでもちゃんと使えば3年間も積んだなっていうことを正面てきた
気がします
めっちゃいろんなものに弾でパソコンとか見れたしカメラとかも入れたしそこで思えば
たくさん囲んでも3年間守ったっていうのはけっこうすごいと思っています
全然にきたねーな角をダメだよ
いやホントにね3年間よく守ったなと思うんですけどもなかなかにドンキのリュックを
3年間使う24歳男性
もういないと思うね3年間使ったリップどうなってるのかちょっと中を見ていこうと
思いますちょっと見ていきますよそんなに特別に汚れているのはその内閣なんですよね
なんかもう全然綺麗
また思ったこと全然壊れてない鉄あることでひっくり返してみましょう
ああああああ
はいっ
wh
うわぁやばさすがに3年間使うとねめっちゃないとリア
全然気づかなかったものを放り込んでただけなんですけどなんかもう内側のポケットが
がっぽり入ってますね御出しっぽいのが出てるんですけど
ホリケン中ではい次いでたら溶けちゃってリュックなそこがハイチュウの沼になった時
がありました
低温よこれもあってこれどこで買ったん
えっドンキで立ってる気がしてきたなあったあった
ネットにしゃべら出てきたし普通に普通に同じ奴がある店内そんな有名なて金ならない
んだ
yahoo グってたんですけど売れてる理由落札されてんの
スッってやれこれどこで買ったんでもドンキだと思うんですけどどこで買ったかもよく
覚えてないんですよね書籍でもたしてドンキで3000円からで打って
た気がするんですよ正直よくわかんないですもうどこで買ったかもう覚えてないんです
けども俺の記憶が正しければ論キーでカッターで気圧のリュック作だったはずですよ
もうカバンの中身もすごいしそれよりもやっぱ3年間ドンキで買ったティックが持っ
たっていうことがすごいですねまぁものは使いようってことですまあそんな負担やで
こので空残念が使ってありがとう
ざいましたプレー賞もない動画です第3年間使ったビッグどうなって皆さん黒門だの
だめじゃんここが泣いてる
これだめだものも人間も同じなんですけどいずれは秋冬客来るんですそれがいつになる
か分からないか
俺たちわ必死に生きて
それはリュックも同じです僕はこのループを3年間使ってん
的下何も思わないんですけどまぁけど本当に何か寝やすい曲に
すぎ使いやすくて文章によってたリックでした
メーカーまだ使い道ないかな形に切りショルダーバッグ白
を
おおおおう
あーにゃりお前
お前つづっ
まだいけるのかも今できるのかう
[音楽]
おっおおっ
me
car
あっはぁ